[موسيقى]
عندما نتحدث عن عدم تأثر الناس
على ما يبدو بالعناوين الرئيسية
التي تمزق العائلات
ووضع الأطفال في أقفاص ، أعتقد في
خيالنا لهذه المشكلة أننا نراها
موضوعة في منطقة جغرافية
تقع بشكل أكبر على طول حدود القيقب الأمريكية
أو ربما بعض
المناطق الساحلية من الدولة إذا
أحب الناس رؤية الخريطة أعتقد أن ذلك
سيكون نقطة انطلاق جيدة للناس
ليبدأوا في التفكير بشكل مختلف حول
قربهم من هذه المشكلة ، لكنني غالبًا ما
أرغب في الاعتقاد بأن السبب وراء ذلك
الوضع هو ما هو عليه في الولايات
المتحدة اليوم لأن الناس لا
يعرفون وإذا كانوا يعرفون فقط أنهم سيفعلون
شيئًا مختلفًا ،
فأنت تريد حقًا أن يكون هذا شيئًا من
شأنه أن يأسر تصورات الناس
التي من شأنها أن تدفع حركة المرور نحو هذه
المشكلة بشكل صحيح وهكذا  كل عبارة من نوع السماء
متبوعة بعلامة تصنيف وهي خريطة X
والتي توجه المشاهدين نحو
صفحة Instagram الخاصة بنا وكذلك موقعنا على الويب
الذي هو X يرسم خريطة لنا وهكذا عندما y  إذا أتيت
إلى موقع الويب الذي
تصادفه لأول مرة ، فلديه خريطة تفاعلية
ستدخل الرمز البريدي الخاص بك أو
ستلتقطه على نظام تحديد المواقع العالمي (GPS) الخاص بك ويخبرك
بالضبط عدد مرافق الجليد الموجودة في
الفناء الخلفي الخاص بك ،
فنحن لا نرى العمل على أنه  نوع من الفنانين
كونهم نشطاء ولكن علاوة على ذلك فنانين
يضخّمون العمل الذي يقوم به النشطاء بشكل
جيد بالفعل باستخدام هذه المنصة
لتضخيم أصوات
الأشخاص المحتجزين حرفيًا ووجدت أنها
مدروسة حقًا فقط أرى أنه
عمل فني وطني للغاية لاستخدام السماء
وهي منهجية مرجعية
لإيصال رسائل الدولة الفخورة
في الرابع من يوليو لإيصال هذه
الأنواع المختلفة من المشاعر التي تثير
التساؤل عما يعنيه أن تكون
أميركيًا في هذه اللحظة
[موسيقى]